[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález hemos sido
testigos en los últimos días de la
escalada de violencia entre azerbaiyán y
armenia en el territorio en disputa de
nagorno karabaj un conflicto que no es
nuevo en el pasado estos dos países ya
se han enfrentado por este territorio y
hay una tensión constante entre los
gobiernos de ereván y bakú un escenario
en donde dos actores importantes en la
región también están haciendo allí
presente en esta escena de conflictos
estamos hablando de rusia y de turquía
cuáles son sus intereses lo vamos a ver
con nuestros invitados diferentes
organismos internacionales y también
algunos mandatarios de otros países
europeos o también de eeuu han pedido un
cese del fuego de inmediato y ordenaron
retomar la mesa de diálogo que hay entre
estos dos países el cáucaso
históricamente inestable otra vez bajo
ataque y enfrentamientos en no es
nuestro tema de debate en france 24
los pongo rápidamente en contexto con
este conflicto que es basta
el largo de explicar pero se lo vamos a
tratar de poner en palabras más simples
durante este programa aquí vemos en este
mapa en la zona que está en conflicto
ven ustedes en verde oscuro está la
región de nagorno karabakh como ven es
un enclave está dentro del territorio de
azerbaiyán pero alrededor
ustedes ven una zona con un verde un
poco más claro estas son zonas que eran
de azerbaiyán pero que los militares de
armenia y separatistas han capturado en
sus avances durante las escaladas
militares en los últimos años esto ha
permitido mantener la franja de la qing
que es un corredor que le permite la
comunicación y tal vez una conexión con
el mundo exterior a la región de nagorno
karabakh a través de territorio armenio
para volver aún más complejo este juego
de fronteras ustedes ven en el mapa otra
región que se llama nai y se van es una
región autónoma pertenece a azerbaiyán
pero como ustedes ven no está conectada
con el territorio de azerbaiyán aclaró
el territorio de náguiz evans no tiene
nada que ver en esta disputa pero les
muestra les deja en evidencia cómo están
las fronteras de estos países que hacen
que esto parezca una
retazos donde cada uno disputa un
territorio y trata de mover sus
fronteras y así lo han hecho estos
países a lo largo del último siglo este
mapa les deja entonces claro estas
disputas territoriales pero también hay
disputas y diferencias religiosas
movimientos poblacionales intereses
políticos intereses políticos
internacionales que hacen que esto sea
un conflicto muy difícil de explicar que
es nagorno karabakh es un estado sin
reconocimiento internacional se
autodenomina repubblica artistas su
capital en la ciudad de este pana que
tiene una extensión de 4.400 kilómetros
cuadrados y cuenta con unos 151 mil
habitantes la mayoría son étnicamente
armenios y también son seguidores del
cristianismo ortodoxo armenio su idioma
oficial por supuesto el armenio uno de
los idiomas más antiguos del mundo más
contexto sobre este territorio del que
américa latina' poco conoce ha sido
históricamente disputado como ya lo
decíamos entre armenia y azerbaiyán pero
sobre todo en el siglo 20 hubo muchos
enfrentamientos entre estos dos países
durante la época de la unión soviética
nagorno karabakh
era una región autónoma que estaba
dentro de la república socialista
soviética de azerbaiyán como ya lo
indicaba yo en el mapa las fuerzas
armenias y los separatistas han
capturado territorio de azerbaiyán que
fue aclamado por bakú alrededor de este
enclave y este conflicto está en un
punto muerto desde 1994 ha habido
conversaciones de paz una mesa de
diálogo que no avanza pero eso sí
constantes violaciones del cese del
fuego por ambas partes
para analizar este tema saludamos a
sergio nahabetián ls presidente de la
organización de instituciones armenias
en argentina se encuentra en la ciudad
de buenos aires también está con
nosotros
anita de la mar icono no va ella es
historiadora búlgara también es ciencia
es internacionalista y docente y también
se une a esta conversación el señor
alfonso soria él es analista político
analista internacional y ex diplomático
colombiano ustedes también pueden ser
parte de este debate deje sus
comentarios en las redes sociales no se
encuentra como france24 bajo ese anti
logo y la etiqueta para que deje los
comentarios es numeral el debate efe 24
pues yo quiero comenzar con anita en la
ciudad de en bogotá desde su perspectiva
como historiadora como conocedora de
esta escalada de conflicto en el cáucaso
porque está teniendo lugar esta nueva
escalada de este nuevo enfrentamiento
entre armenia y azerbaiyán desde su
perspectiva
buenas noches por un rato estamos frente
a un conflicto antiguo pero en un
contexto nuevo distinto así que vamos a
decir hay una herencia fuerte y hay un
contexto diferente si pensemos que en
1994 acabó con un acuerdo en la misa en
la guerra de nagorni karabaj ahí en
aquel momento estaba la transición desde
la caída de unión soviética y un mundo
vamos a decirlo así se quedó después de
la bipolaridad de eeuu extendiendo su
influencia pero hoy en día estamos en
otro contexto
en este momento turquía traté de mostrar
su influencia y fuerza en la región
también de rusia siempre ha estado en
este parte y siempre ha tratado de
mostrar su
a su poderío y eeuu aunque está con la
otan en la región y vamos a decir que
georgia vecina ahí hubo un movimiento de
soldados este verano en realidad es de
dos unidos vamos a decir que se ha
alejado de la región así que yo les
pongo un nuevo contacto un nuevo
contexto puede ser el origen de esta
escalada vamos a conocer entonces un
poco cómo están los puntos de vista
desde el lado armenio y desde el lado de
azerbaiyán le pregunto a sergio en la
ciudad de buenos aires desde su
perspectiva que es lo que ha llevado a
esta escalada en este momento de
coyuntura complicado a nivel
internacional con una pandemia en
desarrollo con países con muchos
problemas económicos y armenia que es
desde su punto de vista pues un país que
está con varios países enemigos
alrededor
buenas noches un cordial saludo desde
buenos aires
muchas gracias por invitarme
si tenemos el gran conflicto un ataque
muy muy grande que hizo azerbaiyán por
supuesto con el apoyo de turquía y esto
es la consecuencia de la armen o fobia
que se fue cultivando en estos tiempos
desde hace mucho tiempo exacerbada en
estos últimos dos meses de hecho tuvimos
las expresiones tanto de ayer del
presidente de azerbaiyán como de erdogán
el presidente de turquía en contra de
los armenios y abiertamente declaran a
venya como enemigos y son heridas sin
cicatrizar heridas que vienen desde el
genocidio armenio producido en 1915
y bueno estas son las consecuencias
cuando no es reconocido y no solamente
el tema no es reconocido el genocidio
que es negado sistemáticamente si las
consecuencias son estas que no se pueden
sentar en una mesa a dialogar y a ver
cómo se solucionan los problemas de
fronteras
si alfonso soria en la ciudad de bogotá
cuál es su impresión de el origen de
esta escalada
muchísimas gracias santiago muy buenas
noches lo importante acá es como podemos
encontrar una solución política a una
ocupación de carácter ilegal y yo creo
que la comunidad internacional no puede
permitirse bajo ningún momento continuar
con los temas de ocupación ilegal yo no
creo hoy hay que darle un avance porque
estamos en una en un conflicto congelado
en el tiempo y que desde 1994 los
intentos del grupo de minsk no ha
logrado el mundo ha logrado una solución
de carácter global para todos creo que
es importante
yo estoy de acuerdo con lo que decía
aneta hoy en día las condiciones del 94
no son las del 2020 hoy estamos con los
actores mucho más fortalecidos no
podemos hablar de la rusia sin la
adhesión de crimea la rusia y la rusia
turquía que se encuentran en libia y que
están hoy en día
y la rusia y que se encontraron en siria
y hoy en día la rusia
y la rusia y turquía que se encuentran
en esta región yo creo hoy en día que es
importante ver todos los los pasos de
negociación internacional para un
acuerdo contra la ocupación ilegal creo
que es importante no es un tema de razas
es un tema de soberanía y respeto por la
región como tal y es un ejemplo para
todos los países del mundo porque nadie
hoy en día podría continuar con una
ocupación de carácter ilegal yo creo que
los principios derecho internacional las
decisiones del consejo de seguridad y
todos son fundamentales pero no
solamente para hacer valer y para
armenia sino para todos los países del
mundo que tenemos porque podría ser un
ejemplo un mal ejemplo para todos los
restos los conflictos que están
congelados hoy en día estancia 2 ya
hablamos de estos dos factores
importantes que son armenia azerbaiyán
quiero que hablemos de otros actores
como yo lo mencionaba hay países que
están aquí implicados en este en este
conflicto y son turquía y rusia
sigo con ustedes alfonso entendamos
entonces cuál es el papel que tiene
turquía
porque está ayudando a azerbaiyán y
porque identifica a armenia como un país
enemigo que es un país vecino
yo creo aquí lo más importante es la
historia de la región y yo quiero
llevarlos a ustedes a 1.880 el proyecto
de pan turismo que existía por los
azeríes que se encuentran en el norte de
gran era una es una sola influencia de
la región desde toda la época de la
invasión mongola y es una cohabitación
aquí en lo importante es no solamente
hablar yo yo creo que estas
civilizaciones han compartido siempre a
través de toda la historia han estado y
creo que uno no puede olvidar hoy en día
y decir que solamente es un tema de
poder de uno y el otro
creo que hay lugar para la coexistencia
y es la importancia de poderlo hacer y
los turcos hoy en día es una sola
influencia de ellos natural y no
solamente yo estoy estamos hablando del
tema de azerbayán podemos hablar del
norte irán türkmenistán uzbekistán todos
los temas y del otro lado esta es
históricamente la presencia de los
turcos
a todas las gerencias de una mala
asimilación durante la época de la urss
yo creo hoy en día que erdogán también
tiene una una gran importancia porque
está jugando a un troll regional donde
lo donde el poco a poco funciona quiero
solamente para para completar que no
solamente es un tema se vayan hace dos
semanas estamos hablando de la presencia
en el mediterráneo y una una diferencia
con grecia en el término y terráneo hace
dos meses estamos hablando de la
presencia de perdón de los turcos en
trípoli en trípoli en temas apoyando al
gan en libia nos enteramos que hay
nuevos actores que se fortalecen con
este tipo de situaciones y ese es un
tema de la geopolítica turca hoy en día
es una realidad
si es una es un capítulo de la
geopolítica actual sobre todo en esa
política exterior turca pero pero esto
tiene un trasfondo histórico
sergio tal vez nos puede poner un poco
más en contexto porque turquía está allí
en este escenario y que tiene que ver
rusia independiente de que estos
territorios pertenecieron a la unión
soviética pero hoy en día qué interés
puede tener rusia en esta región sin sal
díaz pero antes quiero aclarar algunos
conceptos que me parecen muy peligrosos
primero no hay ocupación ilegal
si lo vemos desde el punto de vista de
ocupación ilegal
armenia estaría haciendo algo que no
corresponde y no es armenia acá es
intervino la autodeterminación de los
pueblos
que obviamente a la autodeterminación de
los pueblos está mucho antes de la
integración territorial y si vamos a la
historia el único documento oficial que
hay en donde hacer billar de padre a
cerveza les cede los territorios de
nagorno garapa firmados entre azerbaiyán
y armenia en 1921 el 4 de julio de 1921
exactamente un día después
stalin interviene y cambia ese documento
dice que no tiene valor y cambia sus
fronteras por eso quedó ese mosaico que
vienen mostraste por el entonces hay dos
conceptos que no podemos aceptar uno es
separatista no hay separación porque
cuando cae la unión soviética la
autodeterminación de los pueblos se hace
el referéndum más del 88 por ciento de
la población que vive en esa zona y gana
declararse la independencia con el 99
punto 89 por ciento entonces dicho esto
y obviamente armenia siempre tuvo
relaciones muy cercanas con rusia desde
la época del imperio ruso de hecho el
documento que tenemos que tiene mucho
tiempo es que es un documento firmado
por la sae por qatar y caterina segunda
en donde le da al reinado de armenia la
parte de natural que hoy es hacer bella
obviamente no es una parte en conflicto
y no es un territorio en donde armenia
lo está lo está reclamando porque no han
quedado habitantes armenios han sido
desalojados de esos territorios pero en
nagorno karabaj si el 98 por ciento de
la población es armenia entonces no hay
ni separación ni somos separatistas ni
hay una ocupación ilegal simplemente
el grupo de minsk que pertenece a la
once
obviamente no se pudo solucionar porque
hacer de él se niega sistemáticamente y
creo que en una época de pandemia como
de esta lanzar un ataque y empezar una
guerra porque hoy hay guerra hoy revert
y baron drones se cerca de la capital de
armenia en yereván que no tiene
absolutamente nada que ver por los
territorios que están en disputa
entonces en la relación con rusia es de
mucho tiempo hay una relación tanto o
sea que ahora como perdón hay tanto sea
geográfica como religiosa panetta ha
dejado de última en esta ronda de
preguntas porque quiero conocer su
análisis de estos dos países los
intereses políticos que pueden tener
allí ya vemos el contexto histórico son
países que han tenido relación a lo
largo de los siglos pero en este momento
en la coyuntura que hay qué interés
puede tener el kremlin qué interés puede
tener ankara en esto y sobre todo qué
interés puede tener el gobierno de
azerbaiyán y empiezo y pregunto por
azerbaiyán porque es el que ha dado este
primer paso en esta escala en esta
última escalada cómo está entonces el
contexto de estos tres actores
las preguntas me llevan a decir tres
cosas la primera es la política de unión
soviética en aquellos años confundiendo
dar un derecho de autodeterminación y
después quitar los derechos no sólo a
armenia azerbaiyán que han sufrido de
este política tan confuso que han
construido en aquellos años se entendió
en los años voy a decir que hoy día
voy a ir a turquía
hay algo que bueno como yo soy de
aquella región donde el imperio otomano
se había expandido nos ha dejado una
palabra como herencia la palabra escuchó
esta palabra no se traduce en los
distintos países en la región balcánica
cauca el sur de turquía levante porque
significan vecino persona prójimo a mí
entonces sin entrar en más detalles les
voy a decir quién está destruyendo la
vecindad en la región con seguridad es
turquía está haciendo algo que hace años
no hemos visto en este estado que se
formó como laico a partir de la primera
guerra mundial y hoy día está yendo a un
punto muy peligroso sólo recordar que
pues son con el templo durante su vida
en constantinopla estambul que fue
convertida en una mezquita estos días
sin que sea un lugar respetado entonces
le ves inter y rompe y si será un pelo
ve cinta llegue la guera y ahora porque
azerbaiyán va a atacar en este momento
ustedes fíjense azerbaiyán es un
exportador de petróleo y de gas pero han
caído los precios de petróleo y de gas
en esta época de 40 más 40 en la
pandemia y todos
los problemas entonces muchas veces
muchos estados se hacen a esto desviar
la atención de un problema que es
problema de cómo mantener política
interna desviar a un asunto externo y yo
creo que es pues la razón y apoyo a el
profesor de argentina diciendo que en
agónica airbag tienen 98 población
armenia entonces qué hacer con estos
armenios como 3er pero eres hoy claro
que es una población que además que en
dos momentos como lo explicaba tuvieron
dos referendos uno en el 1988 incluso
estando dentro de la bus y posterior a
la urss en donde terminaron primero a
unirse armenia y en el segundo
referéndum declararse como un estado
independiente que no ha sido reconocido
como un estado independiente a nivel
internacional aquí hay unos actores que
han empezado a sonar y sigo con la neta
para hacerle esta consulta y luego
hablarlo con él sergio alfonso
en países por ejemplo como eeuu mención
a eeuu que puede estar muy lejos pero es
un país donde hay un lobby de la
comunidad armenia muy grande muy
importante allí llegaron muchísimos
armenios exiliados así como llegaron a
argentina y francia presenta el mismo
escenario incluso el presidente macro ya
ha dado algunas declaraciones pidiendo
un cese el fuego inmediato y pidiendo
que la escalada de violencia termine y
empezar una mesa de diálogo aneta cree
usted que pronto entonces francia eeuu
pueden ser estos países que que logren
desescalar este conflicto y calmar un
poco a las partes
sinceramente creo que no pueden estamos
en un nuevo escenario no pueden
influenciar a los países en este
exactamente momento puede ser más
adelante pero en este momento no ya se
perdió en esta esta fuerza de las
grandes potencias por todas muchas cosas
que han sucedido yo no creo que puedan
influenciar
le hago entonces ahora la pregunta a
sergio hago la ronda a la inversa vamos
hasta la ciudad de buenos aires sergio
cualquier este entonces que va a ser el
as bajo la manga que tenga armenia para
sortear esta situación más diplomacia
fomentar la mesa de diálogo aliarse con
otros países seguir combatiendo que
quede usted que va a decidir el gobierno
en yereván
por supuesto que el ataque sufrido por
armenia azerbaiyán apoyado por turquía y
con mercenarios que esto también hay que
decir los mercenarios contratados
de siria es muy fuerte estamos hablando
de hacer de giant con 10 millones de
habitantes y armenia que tiene apenas 3
millones de habitantes
bueno el pueblo armenio es pacífico pero
cuando tiene que defender sus
territorios da la vida por eso
la historia lo dice así estos 4.000 años
de historia lo avalan y creo que
lamentablemente se van a perder
muchísimo más vidas y esperemos y
confiamos en el concierto de países
internacionales que intervengan este y
que no se produzca un nuevo genocidio
porque hoy esto hay que decirlo con
todas las letras y prestar especial
atención hoy se puede cometer un nuevo
genocidio con toda la población que está
en la boca la paz o arzak como se
llamaba históricamente alfonso desde su
perspectiva azerbaiyán es un país que
resulta llamativo por la riqueza
económica que tiene por cómo lo decía
neta por su producción de petróleo y su
producción de gas tiene un aliado
militar turquía e israel le está
vendiendo también armas precisamente hoy
el gobierno de armenia retiró a su
cuerpo diplomático en israel por esta
venta de armas en pleno conflicto al
gobierno de al ejército de azerbaiyán es
un país criticado por sus derechos
democráticos
dinastía que lleva gobernando desde 1994
cuál puede ser el siguiente paso de
azerbaiyán teniendo todos estos recursos
yo creo que lo importante aquí es lograr
una solución diplomática consideró que
todo esto son hay que estar los
elementos dados para una posibilidad de
empezar una nueva etapa y ver cómo
podríamos hacerlo yo creo que el el tema
hoy en día para la comunidad
internacional el hecho de que lo que
ciertos grupos se declaran declararla a
la autodeterminación de los juegos mundo
no conlleva a que el norte se respete
los temas de civilización y los
principios de convivencia o sea pueden
convivir pueden generar estrategias de
paz y creo que es el trabajo de la
diplomacia como tal yo creo hoy en día
que hay que tener hay un factor
desestabilizador en la región es decir
que todo el que no no se puede continuar
con todos los este tipo de conflictos
porque porque como muy bien conocemos en
el cáucaso no solamente está hay que
hablar del tema de
sea osetia del sur daguestán todos y
todos conviven y es la importancia de
vivir aquí no hay y no hay que traer
otros elementos y factores de
desestabilización como los temas
religiosos porque si bien es cierto el
islam el salsero islam chiita wislang
moderno contemporáneo en todo y no y no
hay que olvidarnos que existen 18
millones de aserrí es en el norte de
irán en todo caso esto podría ser un
tema mucho más complejo yo creo que hoy
en día lo que se busca es un consenso
una negociación es sentarse y encontrar
soluciones políticas con el tema del
himno y de la ocupación como tal y creo
que ese es el trabajo de la diplomacia
creo que desafortunadamente estamos en
un 2020 muy convulsionado no solamente
por los temas de la pandemia del cobat
en a nivel mundial sino tenemos unos
eeuu alejados de la región sin ningún
tipo de protagonismo y tenemos una
unas nuevas potencias regionales que
buscan sacar provecho hoy en día pero lo
más importante yo creo que tenemos todo
una deuda con la humanidad es decir de
la convivencia pacífica y la regla es la
posibilidad de poder los pueblos
convivir no sé si ustedes han tenido la
oportunidad porque cuando uno está en 9
por ejemplo en bakú es uzbekos y tayikos
todo el tema y no hay ningún tipo la
convivencia es una convivencia como tal
y yo creo que en eso es lo que está
encaminado le debe estar encaminado la
solución pacífica a este a esta
circunstancia a este impasse y no y no
quiero terminar es decir siempre ayuda
agresiones 2008 2010 2012 en 2014 2016 y
llega y normal ver esto así por todos
tipos de agresiones contra la contra el
pueblo hacer
contra el pueblo hacer y pero así como
usted dice que hay una convivencia
pacífica entre uzbekos y tayikos
kirguises en territorio de azerbaiyán
hay que recordar que los armenios por
seguridad no entran al territorio de
este país y viceversa precisamente por
estos hechos que se han presentado a lo
largo de los siglos deportistas artistas
no van a territorio a seguir por tener
pasaporte armenio precisamente previendo
que les puede suceder algo hace parte de
esta arma ar - fobia que ha ido
construyendo el gobierno de azerbaiyán
sobre este sobre este conflicto en
annette a cómo entender este sentimiento
que se ha construido en azerbaiyán en
contra de los armenios los mismos
gobernantes hablan de ello y lo difunden
en los medios de comunicación y ha
llegado a trascender incluso a
escenarios deportivos escenarios
artísticos que los cito acá
deportistas que no pueden ir a competir
que son de origen armenio y no pueden ir
a competir a azerbaiyán por miedo a que
los maten
yo vuelvo a decir que es muy importante
la vecindad y esto es la base que hace
siglos atrás está aunque si hay un
discurso oficial y duele mucho escuchar
este discurso oficial en la práctica
estamos hablando de una parte del mundo
que tiene una gran diversidad y estoy de
acuerdo con alfonso y es verdad que esta
gente son diversos pero seattle una
bipolaridad y cuando se da una
titularidad esto es muy peligroso
asignar alguien que sea por decirlo así
la maldad de todo esto es lo que hace
escalar el conflicto cuando te centres y
dices que sólo una persona solo un tipo
de población anna es peligrosa si yo
creo que este no es el único lugar del
mundo donde hoy día hay una
a escala de estos odios que no podías y
este escocés pero yo sí creo en la gente
común corriente aquí en bogotá
hablé con una cantante de música de la
orquesta filarmónica y yo sé que hay
gente de ser bojan quien no comparten
este tipo de audio y también el
sentimiento es a la inversa no en
armenia también se siente una gran carga
hacia los azeríes por por por los hechos
que han acontecido me quedan ya pocos
minutos para finalizar el programa
hagamos la conclusión 50 segundos
alfonso que va a suceder en este
escenario una escalada mesa de diálogo
un cese el fuego repentino como ya
sucedió en el pasado
yo creo que vamos hacia el tema de la
paz y una solución definitiva creo que
el trabajo ahora de la diplomacia y yo
creo que hay que avanzar en los temas
también de todos los actores de la
sociedad civil a un entendimiento
entonces creo que totalmente me acuerdo
me identifico con la meta es decir que
el hecho de exacerbar de pronto en
azerbayán no tiene el loving que se
tiene de de la otra parte pero
igualmente hay un interés de la sociedad
civil de vivir en paz y vivir en la
región y no exacerbar todo el tema de
los de los odios regionales porque no
hay que esté solamente la punta del
iceberg y si lo hiciéramos un análisis a
profundidad
sería una el comienzo un desastre a
nivel regional soy yo pero si hay que
dar paso a la diplomacia a volver a
reactivar a mí inscrito diplomacia en el
caso de alfonso como conclusión sergio
cuál es su conclusión que viene más
adelante que va a suceder
bueno el pueblo armenio por supuesto
jamás es agresivo vivió dentro del
imperio otomano en total paz hasta que
empezaron a ocurrir las masacres y hasta
que vinieron los jóvenes turbos con el
nacionalismo turco y de hecho la gran
diáspora armenia no es una casualidad el
pueblo armenio quiere la paz necesita la
paz en ningún momento es un pueblo
agresor con 3 millones de habitantes de
un territorio tan pequeño como el que
nos quedó es muy lógico que sea un
pueblo agresor y hablando de lobbies los
vi de azerbayán es terriblemente fuerte
y utiliza muchísimo dinero en ese lobby
que armenia no tiene obviamente cuando
los gobiernos de azerbaiyán y de turquía
porque daña planeta hizo una excelente
exposición el concuerdo totalmente
cuando hay problemas internos están
buscando este tipo de agresiones como
para poder perpetuarse en el poder si de
hecho el día 12 de julio azerbaiyán
ataca la frontera de armenia que no
tenían
nada que ver con los territorios de
nagorno de la paz
annette a su conclusión 20 segundos
el que yo te diría que en la diplomacia
deben incluir nuevos países de la región
países que conocen este situación y
antes los tomaban como pequeños países
pero ahí es importante que se escuche la
voz de los que conocemos la región y
creo que algo puede dar luz irán que es
uno de los países vecinos tanto armenia
como azerbaiyán ya se ofreció como uno
de los mediadores en este conflicto a
mis tres invitados muchas gracias por
habernos explicado y dejado aquí sobre
la mesa sus puntos de vista sobre este
conflicto ustedes también gracias por
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales siga con france 24
[Música]